in coming to meet Angela Merkel in
Berlin Boris Johnson brought a message
one of a desire to compromise where
possible if his host would do likewise
we in the UK want a deal we seek a deal
and I believe that we can get one we can
do it your shop and us I think is the is
the phrase but clearly
but clearly we cannot we cannot accept
the current withdrawal agreement unfazed
by hearing her own catchphrase used to
her Angela Merkel went straight to the
heart of the matter the contentious
Irish border backstop the backstop has
always been a fallback position if one
is able to solve this conundrum if one
finds this solution and we said we would
probably find it in the next two years
to come but we can also maybe find it in
the next 30 days then we're one step
further in the right direction and we
obviously have to put our all into this
another question for the German
government is what sort of prime
minister they are dealing with one
analyst says ministers here question
Boris Johnson's sincerity that his
journey to Berlin was more about
posturing than politicking we are
talking about a blame game he's coming
here to demonstrate at home once he
returns okay I did everything I offered
our willingness to negotiate to
renegotiate I made clear this is not
acceptable and I got just the no and
then he will follow up on what he
started already so to blame it all on
the EU on Brussels Berlin and France and
then we end up most likely in a no deal
scenario to avert that the Prime
Minister will have to give ground Boris
Johnson's brexit mission is very clear
take it to the key European capitals
where the decision-makers in his opinion
are based Berlin on Wednesday and Angela
Merkel Thursday the French capital and
president Macker and of course mr.
Johnson is clear he wants movement on
the backstop dominic kane al jazeera
berlin